[Music]
cloud shell editor gives you the power
to easily write code from your web
browser
and deploy it to the cloud in previous
videos we learned how to deploy
applications to cloud run
and google kubernetes engine we also
learned about the cloud code integration
and how it provides convenient tools to
debug applications and use google cloud
apis
but what if you want to collaborate with
teammates cloud shell editor has you
covered with version control and support
for multiple projects
let's take a look and learn more first
visit ide.cloud.google.com to launch
cloud shell editor
cloud shell editor gives you the power
to manage multiple projects as
workspaces
a workspace usually represents the root
folder of your project as well as
project specific configuration files
with workspaces you can specify
persistent settings
run and debug configurations and ui
states for all the folders in your
workspace
here we can see some recent workspaces
for this user
to open the homework space that's
created for you automatically click
open home workspace this opens up the
home workspace
displaying all of its folders and files
in the explorer panel
to create a new workspace we'll first
want to create a new directory to use as
our workspace
right click on the explorer panel and
select new folder
give your new folder a name and click ok
let's also go ahead and add a new file
to this folder
once your directory is ready you can
open it as a new workspace
with file open workspace
you can also configure settings for your
individual workspaces
settings are accessible by opening file
settings open preferences
here you can adjust two different types
of settings user settings and workspace
settings
user settings apply to all your
instances of cloud shell editor
while workspace settings apply only to
your currently active workspace
closing the workspace is easy just
select file close workspace
this will bring you back to the cloud
shell editor home page
now let's learn about how to use source
control with git from cloud shell editor
click open home workspace to open your
home workspace
now let's go ahead and include some
sample code from github open the command
palette by selecting view
find command type
git clone and click on it
next you'll be prompted to type in the
git repository that you want to clone
after typing in a github url press enter
to continue collational editor clones
the files for your sample application
from github
into new folder allowing you to work
across multiple repositories at the same
time
right click on the folder created for
your new repository and select open as
workspace
you should see the list of code files
only for this repository
here we have a simple python flask web
application
now let's try editing the code and
pushing the change to github
open the main.py file and replace hello
world with hello google
flagship editor will save your changes
automatically
on the left side of your screen you
should see that the source control icon
has a blue circle with a one inside it
this means that we have a new code
change we may want to commit
click on the source control icon to open
the source control get panel
now we see that we have a code change in
main.py
you can click on it to open the diff
view which shows what you've changed
versus the previous commit
hover over the main.qi file in the
source control git panel
and click the plus button to save your
changes
when you're ready to check in your
changes you can do so directly within
cloud shell editor
but first you'll need to configure git
select terminal new terminal to open a
new cloud shell terminal window
from here run the following two commands
to set up git from command line
[Music]
then back in the source control get
panel write a commit message
and click the check mark to check in
your code change
now you're ready to push your change to
github back in the cloud shell terminal
window
run git push type in your github
username and password to push your
commit to the master branch
let's head over to github to verify that
our change was actually pushed
successfully
based on the information about the
latest commit it looks like we're good
to go
you can also manage source control from
the git status bar at the bottom of your
screen
right now we're on the main branch but
we can click on it to switch to a
different branch or
create a new branch there's also a
synchronized changes button
synchronizing changes pushes local
changes to your upstream branch
and pulls remote changes into your local
repository
with just a couple of clicks we are able
to get started with source control and
push a change to a git repo
if you want to experience for yourself
all the cloud shell editor has to offer
just visit ide.cloud.google.com
where we have interactive tutorials to
help you get started for more videos on
cloud shell editor
and a whole lot more make sure to
subscribe to the channel
[Music]
you